I welcome to this video playing hypnotic
specter from the US really old time
account when I see played him for years
and i see that i know i've activated
this statistics function that I have
actually scored one hundred percent
against him with the Chazz explained
account but I played him numerous times
before so we got a queen's gambit here
with Bishop f4 which favorite of mine
always played this Bishop f4 line even
yeah many years ago when it wasn't as
popular as it is nowadays nowadays
Bishop f4 is almost the main line on a
professional level people are a bit
tired to try to get in get some edge
against on the last covert article one
okay um so he went for a quick c5 yeah
interesting detail XD five is the very
simplistic option nevertheless a move
that probably gives me a slight edge I
could also play on something like
Queenie to try to play for will play
play with Queens on the board ed rugby
one for example okay I'll play the play
the simplistic approach
yeah I expected to have a slight edge
here because I have slightly more
comfortable piece configuration i can
easily plec we need to and look D 1 loop
c 1 x black screen is not so easily
finding a good square mostly because
here I'm a bit quicker f3 before this
one idea and let's say Queenie 7 i have
a three before i'm just quicker with
that and then he's slightly weakened
here c6 d6 right d3 theoretically
speaking is also week on my side this is
symmetrical but my bishop is actually
pointing to the square from f/4 while
his bishop is on a good diagonal but
doing nothing in regards to the disk d 3
square oh this is surprising because it
looks like further loss of temple yeah
interesting rook do you only will
probably go 93 intermediaries and not so
great but i can just just take it okay
let's take it i'm also wondering about
95 in this position just playing in a
very concrete manner if he drops back to
be seven even considering 95
no might be interesting he cannot really
go to a 5 or g6 after Queen f3 it
doesn't look too great attacking the
rook and can only maybe he can play that
habit Bishop f5 option three sixes it's
just strange strange square anyway with
b6 played you would weaken your queen
side enormously so we should be 7s are
just just normal however now that I
think of it maybe I even have some some
better idea right i wanted to go Queen
h5 but let's consider should be some
Queen h5 h6 is there okay he went them
probably because um offer what I what I
mentioned because it was afraid of Queen
h5 okay but this is queen of three
attacking hear it i played this first
yeah come on let's not beat you too
sophisticated to take the Queen it will
win at least a temple and queen of three
Watson additional additional threat so
we have three I can we can block Len
should I'm really just go look see one
yeah I'm wondering if I I have something
more more forceful but this is certainly
not bad just much better developed
ok you spend another move because of
being the before threat which was indeed
an annoying thing
not sure how to continue maybe if not if
not clear what this night is doing 94 to
d6 wood beer would be nice
maybe this is good looks a bit strange
but maybe it is good Bishop f5 I don't
know if he wants to allow that and if he
takes Queen takes as a tempo and i'm
preparing 94 maybe this is good actually
okay we both spent far too much time
actually for for a blitz game but them
ok at least I think I have a very good
position
yeah it's tricky it's tricky i'm also
threatening to take and play Bishop d6
very hard to play this position as black
we have the eye area I take f5 he takes
on g5 but I have the should be 4i am ok
so this is this is quite good takes 35
official before ok is they has something
better than retreating probably not I
still have the bishop t6 idea this
Knight d4 be five or more should I play
now this is also not bad attending
before and weakening weakening black
further
check Knight to c4 would be would be
nice good plan at least exchanging oh I
just blended c4 oops now still it's a
tricky thing with the time the position
is flat-out winning forward you join my
name has far too many weaknesses check
check check check
check check check game drunk oh yeah
yeah those first game his first games in
a session I always slow and full of full
of strange moves strangers being and
quit be six when he just could have
taken the night and other than that that
it looked looked quite okay to me at
least I always had huge pressure this
was a good move I think computer wants
to go nitey form here it's probably
winning in any in any case because white
is just so much better mobilize that ok
yeah it's very difficult for him not to
get in check worse and get much worse
and game maybe I had some more accurate
way to do it but still keeps keeps
everything under control yeah auntie I
just have have to play a normal not
Queen B 6 the end game however I think
close to winning because of the really
bad structure likes got those weaknesses
c5a for and I have this excellent night
on c4 so this should be a win but I
wasn't so quick enough alright thanks
for watching